speaking of women speaking of crazy
stuff
tampax the women's hygiene company
just tweeted out fact
not all women have periods that's true
menopause uh pre prepubescent
also a fact not all people with periods
are women
there you lose me uh i was with you i
was trying to give you the benefit of
that there you lose me
let's celebrate the diversity of all
people who bleed
mythbusting period truths
trans is beautiful so first of all i
guess they thought
this was referring to transgenderism you
know
if a woman pretends to be a man that
obviously she could still uh menstruate
and therefore
if you if you believe that a woman can
just become a man by saying so
then a man can menstruate you know the
the
little leap of logic that's going on
here that isn't totally kosher namely
that you can just become the other sex
by wishing it so
but also this i like the idea of this
phrase
people who bleed we've taken
woman lady
even some sort of disparaging terms for
women broad
dame whatever we've taken different
words to mean woman
and we have taken out all of their
vividness we've taken out all of the
color we've taken out all of
the beauty or you know
[Music]
graphic imagery we've taken it all out
and we've just made it so clinical
people who bleed well that's everybody i
bleed
not that way but i do bleed if you cut
me do i not bleed
if i'd you know now i'm evoking my inner
shakespeare
is that the world we want to live in
where we can't call anything
by any name that has specificity or
meaning or color
or truth to it because everything has to
be clinical and we all have to be the
same
that impulse comes from an impulse
within liberalism which is to make
everybody
exactly the same so men of course men
have to become women
of course any kind of romantic
arrangement has to be exactly the same
as any other kind of romantic
arrangement
of course any kind of relationship has
to be any kind like any other kind of
relationship
of course natural institutions like the
family
or you know very basic institutions like
local government
local townships civil society of course
those have to go away
all to the to the hyper atomization of
the individual
why because then we're all more equal
but we're still differentiated right
we're differentiated on the basis of sex
most notably
so you got to get rid of that too got to
get rid of that too
and i love that it begins with fact fact
men have periods um do you know what
fact means
it tells you a lot about fact checking
i was discussing this the other day on
on the backstage show
over the past 10 years or so now maybe
maybe a little bit longer so
about 10 years we've had fact checks
this is relatively new
as a popular phenomenon in the media the
idea that if some politician says
something you fact
check it there are no fact checks
there's no such thing as a fact check in
the in the popular press
there are left wing opinion columns to
varying degrees of extremism
and they call themselves fact checks
because the left refuses to acknowledge
that there is another perspective
for the left only their perspective is
legitimate other perspectives are
illegitimate
for the left only their candidates are
legitimate the other candidates are
illegitimate which is why if the other
candidate wins they don't accept the
results of the election
which they didn't do in 2016. they still
they still haven't accepted those
results and they have already said
they're not going to accept the results
of 2020.
hillary clinton said joe biden shouldn't
concede under any circumstances there is
no fact check it's
just a left-wing opinion column
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full episode linked in the
description or
download the podcast wherever you listen
to podcasts
you